moi je je travaille sur le phénomène de
l'islamisation et donc toutes les
preuves de cette islamisation toute la
visibilisation de l'islam sous
différentes formes ça peut être les
jeunes femmes par exemple comme vous qui
veulent que il y ait le voile islamique
dans les tribunaux ça peut être
l'offensive islamique à l'école avec des
des jeunes filles qui veulent rentrer
dans les dans les lycées avec leur voile
islamique ça peut être les horaires de
piscine ça peut être le halal dans les
cantines ou alors le fait qu'il n'y ait
plus de por dans les cantines il y a
plein de si vous voulez de de de de
symptômes qui montrent une islamisation
du pays moi je m'intéresse à ces
symptômes et donc lorsque j'en vois et
bien je les partage et quand vous les
partagez c'est dans quel intérêt pour
montrer justement ce qui est en train de
de se passer c'estàd islamation comme un
lanceur d'alerte c'est ça c'est une
islamisation de la France il y a des
symptômes de cette islamisation et donc
je je le montre tout à fait et vous les
montrz parce que vous recevez des
candidatur
spontané ne prenez pas la parole quand
je vous la donne pas on avecia excuse-
rejoign un peu ce que j'allais dire
justement j'allais dire en toute
honnêteté le monsieur donc le
journaliste qui vous a envoyé cette
photo vous verrez verfiez pas à chaque
fois qui est-ce qui vous envoie la photo
tant que vous avez à manger vous le
partagez écoutez ça que vous faites
parce que ça m'étonnerait que tous les
journalistes toutes les photos que vous
avez publié que ce soit à chaque fois
des journalistes qui vous les a envoyé
je fais mes vérifications soit c'est des
gens que je connais et auxquels j'ai
confiance ça peut être des militants de
reconquête par exemple ça peut être
voilà des gens ou alors je vérifie
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont tweeté ces
dernières semaines ces derniers mois si
je vois que c'est des gens qui sont pas
hostiles et qui sont plutôt dans mes
idées il y a aucune raison qui me piège
je recoupe aussi les informations les
lieux la dateid quelles sont vos idées
làdessus parce que moi j'ai V voilà des
tweets voilà vous avez mis vous avez mis
un tweet par exemple en plus de dépenser
de l'argent public pour des projets
humanitaires à l'étranger nouvelle
aquitain banalise et Prome le voile
islamique dans une campagne publicitaire
je vais vous montrer les différents
tweets que vous avez fait comportement
et regards pervers on dit stop témoin de
harcellement sexiste trois conseils pour
agir rapprochez-vous de la personne
harcelée ou agressée adressez-vous à la
victime comme si vous la connaissiez
prévenez un agent TCL ça vous aviez
reposté voilà pourquoi banalise pourquoi
le terme banaliser comme si c'était
quelque chose d'illégal c'est pas
illégal le voile je ne dis pas que c'est
illégal je dis que c'est un symptôme de
l'islamisation de mon pays selon vous
selon vous de notre pays selon vous il y
a pas et c'est quoi l'islamisation et
vous vous êtes le docteur c'est ça
l'islamisation c'est par exemple le fait
que le nombre de musulmans dans mon pays
a été multiplié par 1000 en 70 que le
nombre de mosquée a été multiplié par
1000 en 70 an et alors et alors j'ai pas
envie de devenir le Pakistan j'ai pas
envie de devenir l'Arabie Saoudite j'ai
pas envie que mon pays devienne lib vous
êes mais vos avis mais mais vous vous
avez conscience parce que vous
définissez comme un lanceur d'alerte je
me permets de vous rappeler que le
lanceur d'alerte il dénonce des crimes
ou des délits non si ah si si ah ouais
on sort le code pénal mais vous savez
moi je vais vous répondre sur l'argument
non répondz-moi sur lanceur d'alerte
vous alertez de quoi vous êtes un
lanceur de haine que vous êes notre code
pénal et les lois de la République elles
n'ont pas été conçues à une époque où il
y avait des musulmans dans notre d'aler
musul droit le droit il n'est pas adapté
à la présence de millions de musulmans
et d'une islamisation dans notre pays et
donc ce droitl il va devoir s'adapter la
loi va devoir se corriger pour pouvoir
répondre à la tentative de conquête de
l'islam de l'espace public
not excusez-moi monsieur r mais là vous
êtes dangereux je le savais en regardant
vos
publications voil votre vérité votre
vérité c'est que vous détestez les
musulmans il faut le dire que vous êtes
obdé vous êtes obsé
depulis all dans les pays
arabul quand ilimp pas culture et quand
il Ness pas d'islamiser que vous êtes un
idéolog d'extrême droite vous a
éie
c'est c'est ça vous êes c'est votre réel
fantasm de la
mus géntion ID ce que tu voulais dire
GID ça qui est ironique c'est qu'en fait
son groupe a été dissou pour provocation
la haine et il prétend défend pourquoi
il était dissous pour avoir simplement
fait une frontière symbolique justement
pourf vous savez celui hier à la G du
Nord libien qui a crié au nom de
allahbar et qui qui a tué pardon qui a
blessé très gravement plusieurs
personnes à la gare du Nord vous savez
ces gensl c'est des gens qui passent par
la frontière et doncbolquement quel
rapport avec les mus
symbiement nous av crtière symbolique
parrière depuis 1970 le nombre de mosqué
en France a été multiplié par 24 où le
problème c'est la laïité c'est je crois
pas il y avait ch j'ai dit depuis 70 ans
pas depuis
1970 sur mon avis mais combi même il le
problème la Grande Mosquée de Paris par
exemple en 1950 il avait que la Grande
Mosquée de Paris la grande mosquée de la
réunion
au est-ce que ça vous dérange de votre
quotidien mais ce qui me dérange c'est
que mon pays est en train de venir le
Pakistan et je n'ai pas pas du
tout qu en train de regardez le public
public nous on a un public on a la
chance d'avoir un public vraiment qui
représente je trouve la France dans dans
toute sa splendeur et c'est vrai que
regardez qu'est-ce qui vous dérange
person d'accord avec vous et personne n'
vu quelqu'un dans la rue auss P quand
vous voyez des G qui sont issus de
l'immigration mais voilà qui sont qui
sont is de l'immigration
comm qui font des réussites
exceptionnelles en France qui
emploie des centaines de personnes qui
réuss très bien
voilàè va être avocate pourriez prendre
comme avocate ou pas est-ce que je
pouris le prendre comme
client un avocat prendre
[Applaudissements]
lesoc un avocat normalement doit pouvoir
défendre tout le monde devend tout le
monde oui mais on choisit ses clients
quand même ouis mais mais c'est quand
mmeadame préfèement être l'avocat du du
libien qui a poignardé des
gens tour prend comme
avoc vous la prendriez comme avocate ou
pas du tout je je pense que sur les
problématiques moi je suis attaqué par
les islamistes qui essayent de me faire
taire donc je ne prendrai pas une
islamiste pour me défendre ah une
islamisteah là on va faire appel à mon
avocat par contre pour diffamation pour
un jour public voulez des pruv que je
suis islamiste quand vous likezamine par
exemple qui veut la mort des hom sexuel
vous savez sur votre compte Twitter j'ai
regardé un petit peu les sais vous êtes
abonné à moi depuis quelques mois j'ai
vu vous êtes un fan parms
d'ement quand vous je sais pas du tout
de quoi il parle moi il y a pas de
problème je à la fin de l'émission sur
mon compte
twitteration très précisément madame a
liké certaines sourates par exemple la
sourate 40 verset 60 qui finit par ceux
qui se refusent à m'adorer entreront
bientôt en enfer vous avez liké la
sourate 2 verset 286 qui finit par tuer
notre maître de nous donc la victoire
sur les infidèles vous avez liké la
sourate 23 verset 6 qui explique qu'on a
le droit de faire l'amour à ses esclaves
voilà et puis vous avez liké aussi le
prédicateur ayamin qui réclame la peine
de mort pour les homosexuels donc Madame
voilà qui vous êtes vim et vousur
ouizur j'ai une citation de ce monsieur
qui nsolent rien à voir avec le marage
d'accord mais si vous likez Benladen par
exemple les gens vont comprendre
peut-être que vous avez une
accance derrière un visage la der et pu
communciam Radic voilà il m'a démasqué
alors je vais lui répondre ça va être
très très simple écoutez-moi bien déjà
un on était là pour parler de votre
Twitter à vous pas du mien et le mien
j'asse complètement je sais que vous me
traquez depuis quelques mois je l'ai vu
si vous avez regardé et mêant je vais
vous dire quelque chose non non mais
attendez je vais aller jusqu'au bout moi
vous me faites pas peur moi je tremple
devant personne non mais vous allez
m'écouter non mais vous allez moi je
vous ai laisser parler moi je tremple
devant personne je suis droite dans mes
bottes je suis très transparente et je
sais très bien ce que je fais je suis
très intègre alors écoutez-moi bien non
seulement j'ai lé euh les versets qui
les qui qui dit ils sortent du Coran
mais en plus je les lis puisque c'est
dans mon livre c'est dans le Coran et
j'assume complètement maintenant si on
prend des versets qui ont pris de leur
contexte et qui sont pris ah là il y
avait rien de mal je par attendez je
parle pas encore du tweet de l'autre là
je parle de des versets du Coran
précisément vous ouvrez le Coran il y a
tout écrit dessus vous doutez bien que
si je suis musulmane et que si je porte
un voile je lis ce livre on est d'accord
maintenant att-ons la science pour
prendre des versets comme ça et des
comme ça et vous êtes bien malin parce
que pendant la pub quand vous m'avez
montré les les les versets là vous avez
cité la fin de verset vous avez pas cité
l'ensemble mais ça on y il passera c'est
pas grave ensuite pour en revenir au au
savant donc je dis aux parce qu'il a
très mal prononcé mais c'estirin pardon
c'est un savant con bien ce monsieur
visiblement
vous je connaisis comme je connais votre
nom alors vous êtes quelqu'un d'infem je
connais aussi votre nom donc c'est ce
savant c'est un savant d'Arabie Saoudite
il me semble il a quelqu'un mais pas du
tout j'ai jamais mis les pieds qu'est-ce
que vous me racontez alors là il sort
toute la panoplie je vous dis un truc il
y a eu des rigolos avant vous il y a eu
des Messias il y a eu des oudou il y a
eu des amours vous vous êtes le dernier
ouais vous vous êtes le dernier d'une
long
liste a par que moi tant qu'on prouve
pas trve que les gens sont bien je
voulais juste savoir si j'y connais rien
si ce monsieur que vous avez reliké
et est-ce que vous AZ je pas relé ce
monsieur je sais même pas monsieur à
Twitter j'ai relé j'ai j'ai lé une
citation spirituelle qui n'avait
absolument rien à voir si vous voulez
dire c
citationsieur moi je courent de ses
positions du tout j'ai même pas lu
c'était qui la personne qui l'a dit la
citation m'a plus je l'ai aimé alors
parce que toute citation qu'on a aimé
donc on peut pas dire du je savais pas
côé homophobe je vous crois mais sinon
si vous me dites à côté de ça je sais
pas qu'il avait des tweets homophobes je
mais il a pas des TW homophobes ça vous
comprenez pas cet homme n'a pas Twitter
je crois
il pur idéun a pris une citation qui a
rien à voir avec le sujet de
l'homosexualité une citation que j'ai
trouvé jolie j'ai même pas regardé qu'il
a dit j'ai aimé et com même j'avais vu
je ne suis pas au courant de des
positions de ce monsieurl moi je vais
vous dire un truc parce que là ça fait
déjà plusieurs fois dès qu'on voit une
musulmane avec un voile en fait vous
vous êtes pas content vous tremblez
parce que vous avez djà une
communication excellente je parle M que
vous vous avez rien à me reprocher vous
av vous avez voulu me faire une Manelle
vous avez voulu regarder mes tweets
est-ce qu'elle a aimé un truc sur la
sire il y a rien sur moi monsieur il
m'adame aé des citations c'est tout ce
que j'ai fait et vous tout ce que vous
relayez et vous ce que vous vous êtes un
lanceur de bomb vousê pas un lanceur d'
vous êtes un lanceur de bombbe vraiment
heureusement que le ridicul ne tue pas
mais la haine que vous véhiculez elle
elle tue et vous vous êtes un homme
dangereux moi écoutez-moi bien moi je
suis moi je suis étudante en moi je fais
de mal à personne je fais du mal c'est
bon par contre vraiment vous prêtez à
rire vous donnez à pleurer et c'est
vraiment vraiment triste parce que vous
avez vvoy en enfer ou
pas franchement mais tout le monde en
fait vous êtes burlesque tout le monde
ici vous trouve ridicule vous êtes un
disque rayé mais bien sûr que non je ne
veux pas l'avir homosexuel mais et on en
a à se poser à cette question là je dois
prouver mon humanité parce que j'ai un
vol sur la tête et ben interrogez-vous
dans votre qu arrêtez de parler sur
Twitter on dira photomaton le gars il
est là des photos toute la journée il
sait même pas ce qu'il dit vous là vous
retwez des
trucs écoutez-moi bien j'ai un petit
truc je dis juste un petit truc là les
musulmans qui se taisent et qui ont peur
c'est fini moi je suis droit dans mes
batttes vraiment vous ne me faites pas
peur ah oui c'est fini regardez-moi bien
je dis S c'est terminé maintenant vous
avez une femme j'en ai dans la tête je
suis une femme je porte un voile je suis
pas moin française que vous je plus
française